jean claude gaudin est à la tête de la
ville depuis 1995 il aura face à lui le
socialiste jean noël guérini sénateur
comme nuit bien implanté à marseille un
vrai duel qui aura un écho national mais
la campagne tourne aussi autour de
préoccupations locales les enjeux avec
béatrice gelot et matthew ville il mène
campagne tambour battant
salut et le vert jean noël guérini en
est persuadé la mairie de marseille est
à portée de scrutin le candidat
socialiste s'est adjoint un directeur de
campagne deux fois patrick mennucci très
proche de ségolène royal pendant les
présidentielles
il ya une usure très forte de de
monsieur godet de son équipe qui est une
équipe qui a échoué depuis 13 ans certes
des choses se sont fait à marseille mais
c'est quand même la moindre des choses
en 13 ans mais la réalité quand on sait
que marseille a perdu du terrain sur
toutes les grandes métropoles
européennes et même sur les villes
françaises plus poutine
jean-noël guérini a réussi à rassembler
toute la gauche
du jamais vu depuis gaston defferre
surtout il adopter une tactique très en
vogue
l'ouverture en débauchant deux figures
de la droite locale andré barel et le
docteur française qui ne fait pas
uniquement une ouverture politique
je souhaite que mes dix secondes posit
de femmes d'hommes de personnalités qui
font la richesse de marseille
une stratégie appliquée aussi par jean
claude gaudin même si le maire sortant
refuse le terme de débauchage
dans sa liste un socialiste ans et dans
la cité phocéenne depuis gaston defferre
fait pas du débauchage jeu puis au
contraire une addition de talents et un
homme comme monsieur san marco qui a été
député socialiste cet homme-là
pendant six ans il a été dans
l'opposition à ma municipalité
mais il a toujours fait des propositions
intéressantes il m'a quelquefois fait
changer d'avis et l'arbitré de ce duel
ce pourrait être lui jean-luc bennahmias
l'ex-vert désormais modem entend peser
dans cette élection tout mon chèque mon
parcours politique pour ge plutôt à
gauche que ce soit de toute façon avec
monsieur gaudin guérini il faudra si le
mouvement démocrate est ma personne et
mon équipe sont dans l'équipe municipale
créer une nouvelle journée de paix
gaston defferre jamais marseille la ré
élu un maire plus de deux fois
jean claude gaudin fait le pari d'un
troisième mandat le mandat de trop
espère la gauche